am 18 mai hat nämlich der deutsche
bundestag ein nagelneues
geldwäschegesetz beschlossen ergebnis ab
sofort sind bei uns nicht mehr die
landeskriminalämter und das bka
zuständig für geldwäsche sondern der
gute alte zoll die jungs mit haben sie
was zu verteilen dienstherr wolfgang
schäuble
wir schalten nur leicht nach erfurt in
einem mafia vereinsheim namens zum
fröhlichen beton schuh so ulrich von
heesen ulrich wie kommt denn dieses neue
gesetz bei den betroffenen an
gute frage
jungs wie findet ihr das neue gesetz
hier im vereinsheim hängt jetzt sogar
ein großes porträt vom donnerstag
erklären diesmal früher war 3 125 beamte
zuständig für die bekämpfung von
geldwäsche beim zoll
wenn es nur noch 165 seien für ganz
deutschland
wir haben natürlich von dem thema total
wenig ahnung und kein witz sie kriegen
keinen zugriff auf die daten der
polizeibehörden was sagt man dazu
[Musik]
voller begeisterung für wolfgang was
soll denn das neue gesetz das macht ja
wolfgang denn da blöde frage wer
beschützt dem wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland bis zu 1 06 prozent unseres
bruttoinlandsprodukts kommt aus der
geldwäsche wir sind halt ein wahnsinnig
freundliches land
nirgendwo wird geld so sauber gewaschen
wie bei uns ist doch posting geld aus
drogenhandel waffenhandel prostitution
nicht nur ich nur da ist auch viel geld
dabei mafiageld klebt immer blut gar
keine frage da kann man schon wütend
werden aber dann probierst du einmalige
tollen spaghetti vongole doch kommst du
ihnen einfach immer größer
ich verstehe wurden im wahlkampf machen
alle parteien in deutschland auf law and
order italienischen mafia guck mal
schöne weg die ja warum denn nicht
italiener sind gepflegte menschen des
örtlichen mafia clans steve jobs alle
formulare korrekt ausgeführt ihr antrag
auf einstweilige erschießung eines grund
seien die spendenquittung eine cdu
moment weiß dass hier ihr habt einen
perserteppich von der steuer abgesetzt
wo für pferde
ach da für sie alles korrekt wie schön
ist ulrich von heesen
[Applaus]